wahrscheinlich hat fast jeder von euch
schon mal einen döner gegessen das ist
kein wunder dünner sind nicht nur lecker
sondern ein sinnbild für den einfluss
der türkischen küche auf die
kulinarische landschaft deutschlands
aber was würde man essen wenn man einen
tag lang ist wie in der türkei finden
wir es heraus wir sind jetzt bei längst
angekommen in chorweiler und ich sage
euch so viele leute wir haben die halbe
karte schon bestellt haben gleich ganz
viele verschiedene kleine snacks auf der
karte und den tipp habe ich von euch aus
der community ich hat hunderte
vorschläge durchgelesen und das war
wirklich der wo ich gedacht da müssen
wir hin konnte freue mich sehr darüber
und habe unfassbaren hunger es muss
jetzt losgeht kann ich nach
[Musik]
okay ein schnelldurchlauf was haben wir
das mal so sagen hier anspricht auch
immer von der typischen dafür wurden
auch herzlich empfangen dafür auf jeden
fall ein dankeschön ich selbst schätzen
dann schieß los was haben wir hier die
anfallen dass wir haben hier die
vegetarische platte und dann kommen wir
hier lässt man ganz nach und benannte
nachlässt lässt übrigens geschmack
genuss dann haben wir da vorne melman
und unsere
die einzelnen sachen also die wertung
mit ein bisschen mamola profi haben
schaafs diese das balkanland als bekäme
dann haben wir da geht haben wir bis nur
für einen zuzug zwei verschiedene größen
einmal erinnerung dann haben wir passen
mag ist chrome blog schinken olivenanbau
tomaten guten und sehr beliebt unsere
bahnhofsplatz dies auch selbst gemacht
jetzt ins rollen und unglaublich selbst
ich hab' ich habe so ein hund freue mich
so darauf erklärung ich würde gerade
ungern mit tauschen und das erste also
unglaublich wie haben traditionelle
fangen wir haben so einen schönen teil
wirklich alles alles hier dann macht
hungrig und streiche ich probiere jetzt
einfach als allererstes will ich die
management probieren und dazu gehe ich
einfach mal hier so mit der pille rein
ich hab so dass darauf
cremig ganz leicht auch im geschmack man
muss dazu sagen es ist sehr vielfältig
was wir essen aber ich glaube unsere
außen ist auch sehr sehr opulent also
jetzt einfach sehr viel dabei wir so
unter spannung haben aber man ist der
täter in der regel so viel zum frühstück
sei es auch häufig achse zu einem
wochenpreis ist man dann weniger ist da
ich glaube das ist mein erster start
bringt das zuckerrohr machen dann mache
ich viel zu klein naja die fünf suchen
normaler kann und darf sich gehört somit
wird auch gerne in den scheiben am ende
des tages geht es auch heute so darum
natürlich schmeckt das alles so noch
geht auch darum was für ein gefühl wenn
es um krieg oder ich sage ja das gefühl
jetzt hier vor ist ich will alles ab und
lassen das auch ganz klassisch sicher
habe ich auch immer gesehen bei meiner
recherche immer ein bisschen burg ein
bisschen thematisch ein bisschen was
frisches auch einfach wichtig und gibt
ein gutes gefühl wenn man den tag
[Musik]
startet der industrie mem richtig
fruchtig nur blöd oder ich habe jetzt
schon paar sachen probiert dieses osys
tomatensoße richtig intensiv bewusst hat
so einen kräftigen geschmack ist auch
ganz viel dabei ganz figuration was
fühlst etwas zeit sich etwas fruchtiges
einfach wird schon eine gesamte
bandbreite und wenn du das alles morgens
ein frühstück hast du musst gut in den
tag startet mit ein
wahrer klassiker
heimischen bienen honig rojo das auch
kann man wirklich sagen so eine küche wo
das produkt auch wieder zählt wenig wie
bei italien weil es alles sehr wohl
es ist alles simpel diese gegenpole sind
zu gast beim frühstück wir müssen jetzt
mich rein hauen weil langsam kriegt das
richtig umzug fiel deshalb vollgas und
wir sehen uns gleichen aufgegessen ist
heute das war gerade wirklich für mich
auf meinen hungrigen magen war das wie
weihnachten und geburtstag an einem tag
leute das war's das für mich wirklich
die besonderheit ausgemacht hat von
diesem frühstück wir hatten alles wir
hatten eine leichte schärfe wir hatten
ein süßes wir haben salzig wir hatten
ganz ganz viel frisches und ich sagt
wirklich alles in allem war das ein
absoluter erfolg des frühstücks freue
mich so krass auch heute noch alles
kommen wird an diesem tag aber das ist
für mich das krasse alles ist vertreten
alles vertreten was jede
geschmacksrichtung und das liebe ich da
und harrte artige von einigen auch
dieser wechsel das war immer so zwischen
süß und salzig genau wie xing kann so
wir sind die aktive frühstück als bis
zum beispiel in der deutschen küche hast
machst du dem brot resonant machst du
dann brot und das rad hier sind wieder
papa süß und so das schon sehr sehr gut
und es kann nur gut weitergehen ich bin
wirklich noch randvoll vom frühstück
aber das mittagessen darf natürlich auch
nicht fehlen wir machen heute einfach
ganz simpel ein kleiner snack eine
bietet denn wie gesagt frühstück fällt
sehr opulent auch sehr grosszügig
gemacht was kleines trinkt dazu eine
kleinigkeit auch da haben wir etwas
traditionelles vorbereitet und ganz
genau so läuft das ich fange als erstes
an in dem ich den hefeteig mache er geht
super einfach ich habe hier 450 gramm
mehrere rezepte ist von kies kitchen
wenn ich diese coole gemacht haben sie
aber nach und nach alle zutaten also als
erstes um 200 milliliter lauwarmes
wasser dann 50 gramm frische hefe dann
70 gramm joghurt 40 milliliter olivenöl
halte man auch der größere schiffe ein
bisschen sparen kann man zusehen dann
ein teelöffel seit einen teelöffel
zucker jetzt beginne ich das ganze
einfach mit den händen direkt über
mission so weit ist dann die erste
feuchtigkeit aufgenommen hat geben wir
so einfach auf die arbeitsfläche man
muss auch einfach ein bisschen
gearbeitet werden dass die hilfe gewährt
wird durch die gluten struktur bildet
ich habe die beste technik
fünf bis zehn minuten knetet man den
ganzen dann merkt man darauf seine
konsistenz wenn der schöne rogan ist und
wenn er dann glatte oberfläche hat was
man fertig ist bitte ich eine sehr sehr
schöne form deshalb geben wir ihn jetzt
in die schüssel decken das ganze dann zu
in den ofen bei 15 uhr das licht an und
dann verdoppelte sich in der größe und
sieht ungefähr so aussehen
da schon mal vorbereitet also sehr schön
sehr schön ist dann gehen wir einfach
unseren teig kopfüber auf unsere
arbeitsfläche und so teile mir den teig
jetzt in sechs stücke
und formen daraus jetzt jeweils kleiner
kunde wird hier eine leicht angefeuchtet
ist das gehen mit rüber und in der
zwischenzeit machen wir die füllung
fertig wie man zwei verschiedene füllung
und zwar eine käse füllung wenn die mit
350 gramm gouda gute handvoll petersilie
in dieser schüsse haben wir 500 gramm
hat gleich dazu kommen 50 gramm paprika
markt unsere restlichen petersilie etwas
fein gehackte chili und jetzt reiben die
reine gemüsezwiebel hinein so sieht das
ganze aus wenn es fertig ist also
einfach so eine zwiebel passt
wer diese filme hier vorbereitet könnt
ihr auch einfach schon den backofen
vorheizen
220 grad ober unterhitze alles fertig
wenn die bildung fertig
so alles vorbereitet wir schnappen uns
ein teig wäldchen wo ich hin die fühlen
sich so prescher
kinderfernsehen und rollen das ganze
jetzt wo war auch wichtig zwei
millimeter dünn ausrollen also wirklich
sehr sehr dünn und dann haben wir auch
wirklich eigentlich alles schon das
übermacht steht vorbereitet dann wird
jetzt zeit für unsere füllung die geben
wir logischerweise nur in die mitte
falls ihr titelkämpfe warum klappt
nämlich gleich die außenseiten einmal
nach innen und das gleiche machen wir
mit unserer hackfleisch version da ist
die besonderheit das toppen mit einem
ein später noch und gegeben einfach
unseren rand seitlich auf unsere maße
drauf hier unten zu wirbeln wir den tag
einfach so zusammen und jetzt haben wir
beide geformt jetzt fehlt nur noch ein
schritt wir bestreichen das ganze mit
einer milchleistung das hat schon sehr
sehr gut sodann nächster schritt ihr
fragt eure bezaubernden kamera
für euch eine hälfte lang dann nehmt ihr
gemeint haben dieses backpapier und gibt
es in den profis ist auch nur so möglich
also es ist nur auf diese art und weise
auch traditionell richtig ja ganz
einfach wir machen den backofen zu für
15 minuten bei dann kommen unsere
toppings braucht sich das ganze
finnischen und dann nochmal 50 leute
guckt euch das an und natürlich habt
angekündigt gibt es dazu auch eine
besondere und bringt ihn kennen auch
save ich habe 2000 und gas ausgerollt
der große moment
ich nehme hier als aller erstes mal von
unserer käses youtube in
der schirn wird sich der käse die kinos
kam und auch echt knusprig ich finde
wenn man das so sieht vorsicht hätte man
nicht gedacht dass es so einfach ist
jetzt hier ein ordentlicher bis mit zu
tun
also richtig richtig gut hier unsere
zweite bietet das hat vielleicht nicht
so schön saftig geworden
wir können auch richtig gut aus
ist doch unfair halter
türkische fischer hat was zu bieten und
das wird sich mit sicherheit auch beim
abendessen wieder spielen bis gleich so
es ist abend und wir sind ja auf der
keupstraße einem der hotspots wenn ich
sogar der hotspot für türkisches essen
in köln und hinter uns heute legendär
wir gehen jetzt rein können uns einen
schönen blick ein bisschen was davor
bisschen was danach dann bin ich aber
auch durch studien für heute ich freue
mich trotzdem auf das was kommt der plan
steht wir brauchen als erstes eine suppe
linsen so viele mädchen macd an
alternativer sehr sehr geil sehr
klassisch sehr bekannt und dann
vielleicht haben was süßes hinterher die
verkehrliche teilen uns was also trotz
des leichten mittagessens dieses stück
heute morgen hat so reingehauen aber ich
meine wir haben auch vollkommen
übertrieben trotzdem sehr darauf bald
wann gegessen diese linsensuppe um es zu
sagen habe ich noch nie das war unser
eigentlicher plan wichtig zu sagen von
allem was jetzt kommt haben wir nichts
bestellt wir haben einfach nur gesagt
dass wir gekommen sind um die türkische
küche zu erleben können gar nicht alles
essen aber nicht
das ist diese typische der freundschaft
alter vor zehn sekunden schaffen
wir schaffen das gar nicht es ist
sowieso klar wir wollten
also im vegetarischen stellen wenn man
so in istanbul ist sondern dass man sich
als gast so krass über passt freundlich
empfangen was ist das hier das paar
zusammen verschiedene männer kamera und
stoffe geht
weiter
auch wenn wir das alles gegessen fünf
kilo schwerer
okay wir haben verstanden gesellt gast
günstig da ich gleich bringt er mir so
eine schlüsselperson porsche hausgemacht
abbaustellen ja die höchste heiter die
würden uns keine proteste der himmel
kommen auch gar nicht
verschlafen und wie ist und das war auch
diesmal lassen wir alles teilen ich
hab's darüber angekündigt ich hab mit
hate the sunday verletztes dem ist dann
würde er heute genau das hier ist dj wir
haben uns das sind wir auch schon
gedacht aber das problem ist wir
schaffen das wirklich alles nicht habe
gerade schon zum kennen wir jetzt
einfach die nächsten fünf tage auch
türkisch es und wie es aussieht werden
davon noch jeden fall nichts weg das
wahnsinnig gutes essen kommt mir hier
auch immer das grillfleisch noch
durch man schmeckt so richtig diese
holzkohle aromen vor dem briten fleisch
der burda zubereiten richtig weicht man
hat hier auch wieder alles und herzhaft
mann habe kürzlich man hat wirklich
alles was man sich wünschen kann und ich
bin einfach nach wie vor kommen ja
überwältigt von dieser gastfreundschaft
wie wir erfahren haben fürchten nicht
mehr normal dass hier muss ich noch
probieren das spezial brot mit bonus
bisschen scharf an
heute ist höchst paradies ich dachte du
bist ein schickes design studiert
eigentlich interessant dass du komplett
legal ist in so eine kraft gleich
lastigen kultur so prominente kamen den
eisernen rhein troja sich das so
neutralisiert alles steht und die sind
richtig stolz ob man sieht so er sagt
dass er lacht und wenn man ihre
großmutter außen knusprig und mit
hackfleisch gefüllt
der bauernsalat kommt ich gehe mal rein
petersilie formate wurden durch drücken
so ein scheiß auch das beste an diesem
tag ausklingen zu lassen gespannt ist er
deshalb diesmal zucker rein was soll man
sagen ich glaube wirklich das ziel ist
ja auch immer das stück weit so die
kultur zu erfahren nicht aber nur lecker
zu hässlich sondern die kultur zu
erfahren und gerade mit diesem abend
erstmals den krönenden abschluss
gefunden wurden die könige hier
empfangen und behandelt wenn ihr
authentisch erstmal kommt hier zudem ist
dem stück von meinem zwei sehr sehr
lecker und ich habe viel mitgenommen ich
freue mich auf das nächste land ich
hoffe ihr seid auch dabei und bis dahin
dankeschön ups mit schaum ich war gerade
im urlaub einfach im urlaub kommen jetzt
hier raus jetzt wieder als normal aber
gerade ich habe mich gefühlt wie im oder
das war's